my biggest current concern is we as
conservatives do the most horrific job
at reaching out to the black community
it's like and I mean you know it's not
only on us but it's the fact that it's
like when we get called racist we say
well our fiscal policy is very exact
it's like it's like it's like it's like
instead of calling somebody an
for calling you racist or white
supremacist you know whatever oh no
you're speaking our language
how do we combat that by calling them an
I mean really that's it that is
the actual answer if someone calls you a
racist without evidence this makes them
technically in the dictionary parlance
an but really then it's not
appropriate to have a conversation and
someone calls you a racist with no
evidence your proper response should not
be well that's reasonable let's have a
conversation about this because once you
do that you've acknowledged that a
reasonable person might think you're
racist which means you're a racist right
in the minds of the public so you
actually have to you actually have to
create a basic mutual assured
destruction which is they call you
racist you say no you're just you're
just a jerk right and and then do you
want actually have a conversation about
policy or you want a name throw because
I think you're ugly also so how do we
how do you reach out to the black
community so I mean I I think I think
the way to reach out to the black
community is the same way that you reach
out to everybody which is telling them
the truth I think the message to the
black community should be listen America
is not going to get in your way
and as I said before we will stand with
you every step of the way if someone is
trying to get in your way but you have
to show me the person trying to get in
your way I think that we should be doing
a better job as conservatives of going
into sit into inner cities and saying to
kids here is a like I wanted I actually
would like to do this go into inner
cities and set up a scholarship fund and
say if you get these grades we will pay
for your college and major companies
should do this they should say we'll pay
for your college you work for the
company for four years and that's the
deal that will make with you and so the
job is guaranteed coming out but a
social structure has to be achieved and
sometimes that has to be done
artificially because right now the
biggest problem in a lot of black
communities that there's no real social
structure as far as the two-parent
family where they're telling the kids go
to school get an education and you'll
succeed in America right now is well
over 70 percent of black kids are born
out of wedlock very difficult to have a
very successful social structure when a
lot of the guys that you know have
abandoned their kids or in prison and
that's an individual decision by a lot
of bad people making a lot of bad
decisions so you know
I think that the the best thing that we
as conservatives can do is not lecture
to the black community about you know
all the things that the black community
does wrong but we can say is look we can
all sit here bitching and moaning about
how the United States is a terrible
place and the Democrats will be happy to
do that with you all day they will
they'll be happy to sit here and
and moan and then go to Washington DC
and do nothing for you
nothing for you but if you actually want
to succeed here's how we're gonna
succeed we're gonna sit down right now
and I'm gonna make with you right now
individually a success plan for you and
if you stick with this plan every step
of the way I guarantee you that by the
time you're 25 years old you won't be
living in a hovel you're going to be
living in a nice apartment in a decent
area with the job I guarantee you that's
what's going to happen it has to be done
not on a governmental level on an
individual level because here's the
thing we're all either they're dependent
on government or were dependent on
capitalism and so we have to make people
dependent on capitalism again we have to
make people dependent on markets again
and on freedom again and not on
government again
[Applause]